وما قد يثير خلافا بين الولايات المتحده
والصين حزمه مساعدات جديده لتايوان
فالكونجرس يسعى لتسليح تايوان بسرعه مع
تمام التهديد الصيني عبر مساعدات عسكريه
غير مسبوقه لباي قال مسؤولون ان المساعدات
ستسمح للجيش الامريكي بتوفير الاسلحه لاول
مره لتايوان من خلال برنامج التمويل
العسكري الاجنبي هذا البرنامج يمكن تايوان
من تلقي اسلحه ومعدات مثل صواريخ وانظمه
الدفاع الجوي والطائرات المسيره وانظمه
القياده يرى مشرعون امريكيون ان الدروس
المستفاده من حرب اوكرانيا تدفع لتسليح
تايوان وتدريبها مسبقا قبل اي هجوم محتمل
من الصين قال النائب مايك جالادور ان
الولايات المتحده بحاجه لتسليح شركائها
قبل بدء اطلاق النار وهو ما يمنح لاي دوله
الفرصه لتجنب الحرب لكن العقبه في الوقت
الحالي
هي عدم وجود اموال لهذه الحزمه في مقترحي
ميزانيه العام المقبل والذي يعمل الكونجرس
على تمريرها واذا لم توجد مخصصات ماليه
لتغطيه تكاليف الاسلحه سيتعين على الرئيس
جو بيدن تقديم طلب طارق لتمويل الانفاق
لتايوان وتوضيح السبب وراء ذلك اعضاء
بالكونجرس قالوا ان الحزمه التي يتم
الانتهاء من تفاصيلها في قانون تفويض
الدفاع الوطني ستسمح بتزويد تايوان سنويا
بما قيمته مليار دولار من الذخائر
الامريكيه المخزنه وما يصل الى مليار
دولار من الاسلحه السنويا لمده خمس سنوات
مدفوعه باموال الضرائب الامريكيه يقول
مسرعون في الكونجرس ان المساعده ستكون
متسقه مع التزامات الولايات المتحده بموجب
قانون العلاقات مع تايوان الذي ينص على ان
سياسه الامريكيه تجاه تايوان تقضي
بتزويدها بالاسلحه لتمكينها
دفاعي عن النفس على الطرف الاخر يتسائل
مشككون عما اذا كانت المساعده ستعزز
القدرات الدفاعيه لتايوان على المدى
القريب مع الفارق الكبير في القوه
العسكريه بين تايوان والصين لا ننسى
تحذيرات القاده العسكريين الامريكيين
السابقه من مطامع الصين احدها هؤلاء
الادمن الذي كان قائدا للقياده الامريكيه
في المحيطين الهندي
حذر قبل نحو عامين من ان الصين تريد
تحقيقه مكانه القوه العظمى بحلول الذكر
المئويه لتاسيسها عام 2049 وهو ما سيعني
ان تايوان هي احدى طموحات الصين قبل ذلك
الحين وفي ذلك الوقت فسر مراقبون هذه
الملاحظات بانها تعني احتمال حدوث غزونيه
لتايوان بحلول عام 2017